نعم انا ساتحدث عن مشاهدات بين ولايتين
انا قبل يومين كنت في مدينه اضنه الدمار
في اضنه محدود ولا يوجد هذا المشهد الذي
نشاهده الان في مناطق معينه هناك بناء
مهدم وهناك بعض المباني المتصدعه الشرطه
هناك يعني الدمار لم يكن كبير استطاعت فرض
طوق امني على جميع المباني المتصدعه
وايضا المباني العايله للسقوط وبالتالي تم
ضبط هذا الموضوع موضوع السرقه او موضوع
النهر لكن هنا في هذه المدينه المنكوبه
بالكامل يعني وخلال جولتنا اليوم
فجرا وايضا خلال جولتنا يوم امس اعتقد ان
اعداد الشرطه غير كافيه لضبط هذا الموضوع
او اعداد الجيش واذا سالنا لماذا اعداد
الجيش والشرطه هنا غير كافيه ايضا هناك
مناطق اخرى منكوبه بالكامل تحتاج الى
اعداد اضافيه يعني حجم الدمار حقيقه لكن
مع ذلك هناك دائما محاولات لضبط هذا
الموضوع وهناك تحقيقات بدات وتم القبض على
48 شخص يوم امس تم الاعلان عن هذا الموضوع
كانوا يحاولون سرقه بعض المنازل التي
تركها اصحابها بالتالي هذا ايضا
تخوف جديد
للحكومه التركيه والسلطات الامنيه هنا من
ازدياد اعمال
السرقه والنهب وهذا ما تحاول ان تتعاطى او
تتعامل معه في اسرع وقت لكن على ما يبدو
ان المهمه صعبه جدا حقيقه اسامه